I'm really excited to have two of my
interns be presenting their work today
the first up is Natalie she's a senior
at Oregon State University
she's a microbiology pre-med major now
since she's microbiology and I study the
microbiome I was kind of anticipating
that she'd be interested in working on
some of my microbiome pipelines for
analyzing the sequencing data but she
actually really wanted to understand and
get involved with clinical research and
recruitment so her project really
focused on trying to mine and analyze
the recruitment data that we had from my
previous studies and also getting some
exposure to the clinic to the clinic at
the Center for Women's Health here at
OHSU all right okay so good afternoon
everyone thank you for that introduction
VESA so today I will be presenting on
data driven shifts and critical clinical
recruitment strategies so just an
outline of my talk today first I'm going
to give an introduction to overactive
bladder and the general participant
involvement in this study and then talk
about the recruitment in the initial
study and then building off of that
initial study recruitment how that guy
did the recruitment change in the
current state that we have going on
right now finally I'll talk about the
future steps in this study and my
internship takeaways so an overactive
bladder is characterized by the detrusor
muscle in the bladder squeezing too
powerfully or too frequently resulting
in urgent and frequent urination this is
really important to study because it's
highly prevalent in both women and men
especially in older ages and also it has
a high correlation to stress and anxiety
the stress and anxiety results in an
effect on the quality of life and many
people especially regarding limiting
socialization due to restroom
availability also overactive bladder is
not well understood mainly because it's
causes and it's
treatments aren't well developed in this
particular study we focus on
postmenopausal women and have three
groups they can be categorized into
those three groups are overactive
bladder wet where leakage occurs from
urgency and frequency overactive bladder
dry where leakage does not occur from
urgency and frequency and then the
control group which experiences no
overactive bladder symptoms this is an
overview of participant involvement in
this study so initially a participant is
contacted either contacts the research
unit on their own or is contacted by
someone in the study then there's
eligibility is assessed via a phone
screen then if eligible they would be
scheduled for a study visit their
samples would be collected and their
data would be analyzed and that
participant would be enrolled my big
question for this project was how can we
use past recruitment challenges to guide
our recruitment strategy in this current
study I attempted to do so by addressing
these three points recruitment
documentation challenges the community
reach and participant retention and
interest so recruitment in the initial
study used in many referral sources some
of these being online different Flyers
Facebook and then some provider
referrals recruitment was documented in
an excel file this was initially made to
be assessable amongst the study team but
also serve as a source of communication
for the study team which had multiple
people doing recruitment but similar to
the EHR because multiple people are
implementing and these had free response
cells we had lots of different
interpretations and lots of different
verbage going into the excel file making
a nun standardised source which created
many different fields this an example of
this was it had 14 enrollment sources
and 68 referral sources as seen on the
on the right side of the screen here
this inconsistent data entry makes
participant data really difficult to
track first of all because of the
referral sources that came out of it as
you can see on the left there are many
different variations of just flyer some
of these capitalization errors
some of them having locations some of
them not but also it made it difficult
to come to track which Khan contacts
were actually enrolled so he had one
file for people that were contacted and
in one file for who was enrolled in the
study but we didn't have a way to map
those two together and then finally we
were interested in at what point if I
needed a participant lose interest in
involving being involved in the study
going forward and referring to this
right-hand side list which is not
exhaustive because it's not all 68 of
the term referral sources that were
found we wanted to consider
capitalization but also to general of
statements like online and then also to
specific to specific of statements like
names of study coordinators or friends
because the spreadsheet was not
standardized plotting the referral
source against the enrollment status
gave a really messy and ineligible or
illegible plot I've shown up here on the
top left so then we went through this
data cleaning process to produce a more
informative and more usable plot here
however cleaning and tidying data is not
as easy as just sweeping up with a broom
so you have to consider what tidy data
actually is so tiny ADA has each
variable has a column each observation
has a row and each value has a cell to
do so you can use various are packages
like tidy up data table and do plier to
join subset data sets and to get out
variables that you need but also like
you saw in the earlier figure we needed
to standardize those names so you can
use levels and character strings to turn
all those little left's into flyer
however when you're cleaning the data
you need to have a goal in mind for
example if you wanted if you were
interested in those locations that those
fliers came from you might not change
all of those little left's into simply
flyer you might keep accounting for the
location in which they were hung but
this is just a summary of that initial
data cleaning regarding the referral
sources and the enrollment statuses so
in the unclean data we had 68 referral
sources which turned into 14 and then we
had 14 enrollments acids which turned
into seven
in addition to those tidy referrals I
mentioned that you do have clear
enrollment statuses after cleaning that
data so not surprisingly not all
individuals who are contacted at the
beginning of this workflow end up being
enrolled in the study that's just the
case with clinical researcher research
in general but I wanted to pull these
enrollment outcomes with the hope of
depicting where in this sequence people
lose interest but that data was
unfortunately not available to determine
exactly if it was after contact after
eligibility or after their study visit
but from these different options of loss
of interest you can kind of infer where
they might be the loss to follow-up one
is a bit ambiguous that sounds like it
was after contacting the patient after
they expressed interest the first time
and then there are these not interested
categories due to specific reasons the
biggest of which was at the catheter in
this study we are interested in the
microbiome in the bladder and so we used
a catheter to obtain the bacteria in a
bladder without contamination and a lot
of people were uncomfortable with this
procedure other options of not intra or
not being interested was the trip to
OHSU compensation or just other things
going on in their lives another part of
not being interests in the study that we
can't really do much about is being
disqualified from the study whether that
be having a consisting condition that
makes them ineligible or being on
antibiotics which in that case we have
to revisit them later on in the study
see if they're eligible then and that
follow-up sometimes results in them not
being interested in longer so a question
that I had going forward just because we
didn't have information on exactly when
the referral lost interest or the
participant lost interest I wanted to
know if some referral sources have a
higher retention rate than others so to
evaluate this community reach and also
retention I made this plot of passive
and active recruitment approaches so
passive recruitment involves all sources
that are out in the community or that a
participant sees and contacts the
research unit on their own where an
active recruitment is a direct targeted
approach where physicians or
study team or any other option that the
participant is identified as a possible
participant and then contacted by the
research unit so in this case our
passive recruitment included Flyers
newsletter newsletters Facebook etc and
our active recruitment included the epic
coke or it might tart messages and then
also provider referrals based on this
proportion plot it's not very conclusive
to decide whether or not active
recruitment does have a higher retention
for participants though it is only 0.5
percent higher on this on this plot but
past literature does suggest that a
direct targeted approaches and in higher
participant retention and also we have
this unique opportunity to begin
recruitment in the Center for Women's
Health prompting the study team to take
advantage of that extra active
recruitment here so this leads me to the
current study recruitment based off of
that initial study insight so in the
current state of recruitment I still
wanted to consider those three main
points where that recruitment
documentation to standardize the data
was really crucial first of all that log
in Excel was standardized by adding
drop-down menus pretty simple but it
exponentially improved the
standardization of this recruitment log
also we started using this database
called redcap which can hold all of the
questionnaire data all the study visit
data and can be easily pulled from so
you get subsetted data frames without
having to look at thousands of variables
at one time also at this community reach
aspect we wanted to continue to utilize
passive recruitment platforms mainly
because they were effective and also it
has little user or study team time and
going out into the community also we
wanted to begin this recruitment in the
center of women's health just to explore
that impact of that active recruitment
and then also by doing so we identified
participants in the cwh that could be
eligible via epic and then talk to them
in person about their
or their interest in this study through
that we wanted to explore the efficacy
of the participant interest and
retention in cwh this is a general
workflow for the cwh system so first of
all we had that participant recruitment
which involves that initial contact then
the data was entered and verified in
redcap that big database that I talked
about earlier and then we cleaned data
with different our packages as I
mentioned and then we visualized and
analyzed in our studio this workflow may
look simple but it's really important
for reproducibility of this work
recruitment is ongoing even after my
internship is done and so at that redcap
level or even at the participant
recruitment level new files can be
uploaded into this workflow and ran to
have a similar analyses so just like
you've seen before we have this dirty
era and we have this clean data but even
looking at this first plot of the dirty
data this comes from standardization of
the log to output a much neater still
readable file as compared to the
completely unreadable one sonnet that we
saw in the initial study let me go
through this same tidying data process
to output our clean data file to show us
our referral statuses via or versus our
enrollment statuses so to zoom in on
those three most common referral sources
we look at cwh clinic facebook and
newsletter you can see those here say VA
cwh Facebook and newsletter were the
three most common
so just for a reference this plot on the
left hand side is before my internship
so that's one year long of time and then
on the right hand side is that ten weeks
I've been here from late June to now
it's also important to note that these
large blue sections are disqualified or
not interested
portions of that recruitment
unfortunately this is just
characteristic of clinical data or
clinical research but it's emphasizing
the difficulty of
participant retention so just zooming in
a little bit more and to just the Center
for Women's Health section this plot
also shows enrollment and referral based
on contact time so on the Left this is
actually a five month period because
they didn't begin CDH recruitment until
february of 2019 so this is from
February to late June and this is from
late June to now the difference between
these two plots is just the time spent
in cwh and the emphasis on this active
recruitment so on the right hand side or
the left hand side not very much time
with spending per week and the
appointment flow or the appointment of
volume wasn't really being considered
but on the right hand side I would spend
48 hours a week in the clinic carefully
looking at when there were many
appointments or many patients to be seen
waiting around in cwh is a large time
commitment especially for people that
have other study recruitment efforts
going on and so if I would try to go
during times I would have 12 patients in
like four hours versus two patients in
four hours and that makes a really um it
makes takes advantage of the time that
you have additionally I wanted to note
that because my internship is ending I'm
unable to fully decide whether this big
pink area shows that the cwh or
increasing cwh recruitment made that
great of a difference on overall
retention because this middle darker
pink area is still patients that are in
follow-up so those participants are
still able to become not enrolled or
enrolled in the study building off of
that this plot here on the right is
again the participant retention plot
with proportions versus active and
passive recruitment so that the two bars
on the left those are enrolled versus
not enrolled for the year portion and
herb for all of the recruitment from a
year ago until now
and until this darker pink in the center
becomes either enrolled or not enrolled
we're unsure whether this active
recruitment makes a huge difference or
not however as you increase participant
reach or community reach you're getting
more contact with patients and you have
a higher probability of participants
being enrolled to go back to this
recruitment documentation for the future
I would advise continuing to standardize
the documentation depending on what your
goals for your research are so for
example earlier I mentioned that I would
like to know where along that
recruitment line participants are no
longer interested so maybe taking those
are making more specific measures on
that but obviously you can modify that
excel log as needed and still keep it
accessible to all the study team that
would need it and it's relatively easy
to use also for community reach I would
utilize passive and active recruitment
continually first of all because this
Facebook and other online or newsletter
sources are really effective and they
reach a larger amount of people at one
time than talking to people in the
clinic but talking to people in the
clinic does create that sense of
community and they can get their
questions answered and concerns put to
rest right there versus an online source
you're at risk for trolls or people that
don't fit the eligibility standards and
so forth lastly participant interest in
retention because we still have so many
in this in follow up stage as is
participer the study is ongoing
I would love to revisit this and then
have a greater sense on whether this
active or passive recruitment ends up to
be favored over one another
so overall takeaways from this research
time I really don't are as a data
cleaning a statistical tool something
that I had a little bit of familiarize
ation with but not a lot so I was really
excited about that and I feel like I
accomplished that goal but then also I
am a pre-med student and seeing that
clinic flow and getting that exposure to
how physicians operate and how
participations are perceived and the
clinic was a really cool experience and
also just in general valuing
documentation and reproducibility our
markdown was great for this because I
learned the value of annotating my code
so I knew what I was doing when I
revisit it and then re-evaluating
potentially restructuring your
methodology for that same reason and
going back and seeing how things maybe
didn't work how you thought they would
and then finally taking the advantage of
resources whether that be dr. Carson's
my fellow interns mas or physicians in
the clinic or just my um friends around
or experts in the room finally I want to
acknowledge dr. Carson's for taking our
interns on this summer and then the de
maiz program for making this all
possible and the National Library of
Medicine gran thank you
[Applause]
okay thank you
[Applause]
getting set up I'll introduce Selene
Celine's also a rising senior at Oregon
State University
she is a bio resource research major and
pre-med her primary goals for the summer
was to learn more about human subjects
research as well as improve and learn
command the command line and also
scripting so she worked on my project
that involves looking at how the brain
regulates bladder function and she's
going to talk to you today about
understanding the connection between the
brain and the bladder and some of the
exciting analyses that she did with
processing thinner imaging data that
we've collected in my research so born
thank you for that introduction dr.
Parsons so I will be switching gears a
little bit and talking about another one
of Lisa studies and my work this summer
focuses on understanding the connection
between the brain and bladder and in
subjects with urgency urinary
incontinence so a presentation overview
I'll first talk about the urgency
urinary incontinence study and then give
a brief background on neuroimaging and
then follow that with information on the
human connectome project pipeline that I
used to analyze my data and then talk
about the adolescent brain cognitive
development quality assessment it which
is a protocol that we use for quality
control and then I'll talk about what
the future for this project entails fall
and then ending with what I've learned
this summer in my internship takeaways
so what is urgency urinary incontinence
so urgency urinary incontinence is a
severe subset of overactive bladder so
women who suffer from urgency
incontinence have frequency urgent
urgency and leaks so that means that
when they have the urgency to urinate
then it follows with immediate leakage
and this has high economic cost and it's
a burden on their quality of life and
about 19.1% of women between the ages of
65 and 74 in the United States have
urgency incontinence so it's important
to study it and the purpose of the study
is to investigate how the brain and
bladder connect and we do this by
identifying structural and functional
differences in the brain between women
with urgency incontinence and women with
no history of overactive bladder and our
approach was to utilize structural and
functional brain imaging techniques as
well as the human connectome project
pipeline that we process the data
through to combine different modalities
of imaging data to compare across
subjects
so this is an overview of the data
acquired for the study so we have 36
women that are controls and these women
have no history of overactive bladder
and then we have 58 with urgency urinary
incontinence so we collected their age
BMI and history of incontinence
treatment and if they did receive
incontinence treatment what type of
incontinence treatment they received and
then we used validated questionnaires
that we used to assess incontinence
symptoms in their overall quality of
life and pelvic disorders so the
international consultation continence
questionnaire was used to evaluate
severity frequency and impact of quality
of life and then the urinary distress
inventory was used to evaluate frequency
a urinary leakage any difficulty
emptying their bladder and any pain or
discomfort they felt in their pelvic
area and then we asked all the subjects
to have a bladder diary that was
self-reported so we asked them to keep
this for over a three-day period and we
collected frequency urgency urge leaks
nocturia episodes and fluid intake and
then this was average to find the
average per day for each variable and
then lastly we collected neuroimaging
data so we collected a structural MRI
scan a functional MRI scan and the
functional one was collected with the
bladder filling protocol that was used
to mimic the emptying and filling of the
bladder and there's two types of
functional scans collected one was a
resting state one and then one was a
task-based one and the purpose of the
resting state scan was for a
co-registration for a trims forming the
resting state and task feet stamp these
scans together and then the fMRI scans
was used to see how different brain
regions react to the emptying filling or
at rest so this is some background on
brain imaging so I'm going to compare
structural and functional brain imaging
because those are the two that I used in
this study so magnetic resonance imaging
uses strong magnetic fields to acquire
images so structural brain imaging shows
brain structure and it has high spatial
resolution and
example of that would be the t1-weighted
image which is up there on your left and
then functional brain imaging maps brain
activity over time and this one has low
spatial resolution and it uses a blood
oxygenation level dependent which is
bold so it measures brain activity
through blood flow and this is because
when there's neural activity then
there's an increase in oxygen
consumption in that region of your brain
so your body will respond by increasing
blood flow of oxygen-rich cerebral blood
to that area of the brain and then an
example of this would be the resting
state in task-based scans up there have
an example of a resting state functional
connectivity MRI it's a reference image
and then this is a hierarchical
structure break down a data acquisition
of MRI data so we had one experiment and
within our experiment there was numerous
subjects and in each subject we'll have
few sessions so then which within each
session there'll be several runs and
then each run has a series of brain
volumes and then each of volume has
multiple slices and then each slice will
have many voxels and each voxel will
have one intensity associated with it
which means there's a lot of data
acquired during this process and so on
your left there's an image of a matrix
and that blue box represents one voxel
and four just to give you an idea of the
size of it for pre-processing data it
could be upwards of one gigabyte and
then for post-processing data it could
equal three gigabytes or more but that's
just the average per session so if you
are having multiple sessions within a
subject then your data size will
increase so this is the bladder filling
protocol so subjects are catheterized
and connected to a urodynamic pump that
mimics the bladder filling and emptying
so there's an infusion of saline and
withdrawal of saline so prior to that we
take a structural MRI scan and then to
resting-state scans
and gee resting-state scans where their
bladders empty and then we fill their
bladder with a hundred milliliters of
saline and then these are two empty
blocks and each block will have four
runs and within the runs there's a
saline infusion and withdrawal phase
that is happening right here so in these
two blocks there's one task based fMRI
scan taken with an empty bladder and
then the second task based MRI scan with
an empty bladder and then after that
we'll fill their bladder until the
subjects have a desire to void and then
they'll let us know and then the full
bladder resting state is taken and then
followed with two more blocks of
task-based scans but with a full bladder
so again those blocks have four runs
each so this is the adolescent brain
cognitive development human connectome
project pipeline that's we just use
acronyms so it's ABCD HCP fMRI pipeline
makes it easier to say so the deccan lab
which is the developmental cognition and
neuro imaging lab here at OHSU has a
modified version of that that they use
and this is a minimal pre-processing
pipeline that we put our data through
just to remove less information and keep
as much data as possible so it brings
multimodal
data together to be compared across
subjects for this particular study we're
combining modalities of t1-weighted
image t2-weighted image the resting
state and the task based scans so the
input for that is brain imaging data
structure which is something that the G
chem lab uses so their pipeline has a
bids initiative built on top of the HCP
pipeline just to make configuration
easier and then the output is a
connectivity informatics technology
initiative which is called a safety and
within the HCP pipeline you can use
special pipelines options so if you're
working with a specific subject or like
specific population such as an older
population or a neuro George
you can input a template and that will
make your results better and then the
ABCD Quality Control is a standard
operating protocol that the D can lab
uses to assess the quality of all the
images required acquired so you're going
to assess both the structural and
functional scans and these are rated on
high quality medium quality or low
quality so this is an example of
structural quality assessment so on the
left side I have a quality assessment of
one which means that they're high
quality scans and then on the right side
I have quality assessment of three which
means they're the lower quality scans so
what you're looking for is a gray matter
which is the red lines it's a little
blurry but I promised you the red lines
are there and what white matter which is
the black lines so you want to make sure
that they're not intertwining with each
other and then you can clearly tell
between the gray and the white matter so
you can see that they're delineating on
the left side but on the right side that
there's some distortion up here at the
superior parietal and then on the right
temporal there's also some distortion
which means that it's going to receive a
quality assessment of three because
you're not going to want to use a scan
with some distortions in it and then
this is a functionally quality
assessment so again I have the
higher-quality images on the left side
and then the lower quality on the right
side so the top row is the structural
overlaid on the functional and then the
bottom row is the functional overlaid on
the structural so for these ones you're
looking for any dropout or fuel the view
errors and again for a distortion
they're works of the brain for on the
high quality images there's some minimal
temporal dropout or a year but that's
fine because it's very minimal and it's
not affecting the brain at all the brain
imaging but on the right side you can
see that there's some feud of the field
of view error and cut off of the
cerebellum
Vox tibideaux lobe and temporal so we
would not use that skin for analysis
because a lot of the brain was cut off
during imaging so this is a post
regression granites and motion numbers
graph so we use the post regression
because it shows the whole regression of
the brain and we're looking to pinpoint
motion points of during data acquisition
so on this side this is the frame
displacement graph right here and then
this is the great ordinates graph and
you're going to want to look at both of
them when you're determining if the
subject has moved too much during data
acquisition so when you're looking at
frame displacement graph there's a
threshold that is usually determined
during analysis and in most cases it's a
point to threshold so right here the
yellow line is the point to threshold
and you want a majority of your frames
to be below that line so on the left
side you can see a majority of the
frames collected is below that threshold
whereas on the right side a majority of
it is above that threshold and the
vertical static bars indicates motion
during data acquisition so on the right
side you see that the subject was moving
a lot and there's a ton of those
vertical bars and that tends to happen
in the cases with urgency incontinence
because when you fill their bladder
they're uncomfortable and they're going
to move a lot on and they can't stay
still during the MRI and whereas in the
subjects with no history of overactive
bladder they're fine and they aren't
aren't uncomfortable with a full bladder
so this is just an overview of quality
assessment so this is the total number
of scans that we acquired in this
project and then as you can see a
majority of the scans though we
collected were of high quality so I
divided it up as functional rest
functional tasks in structural and a
majority of them are of the in the one
category which is high quality and
there's very few that are of low quality
so for next steps is to decide the
quality cutoff for inclusion so we would
determine quality thresholds and then
test out those different quality
thresholds to see how many subjects are
taking out depending on how strict that
threshold is and you also need to keep
in mind how many subjects you want to
move forward for analysis and what type
of analysis you want to do so we were
going to do an F con anova which is a
group comparison of brain activity so we
compare the brain activity of the
subjects with urgency countenance versus
the subjects with no history of
overactive bladder and then the next
analysis would be the F con regression
which is association with symptom
severity so we would be looking at the
validated questionnaires scores that
were collected in the beginning as well
as their bladder Diaries like how many
frequency urgency or urge leaks nocturia
episodes and fluid intake they had per
day some internship takeaways um so I
learned the importance of computational
data organization very early on
especially when you're working with big
datasets so when you're using multiple
pipelines or tools or graphic user
interfaces you should have input and
output folders for each of those tools
because um you're going to be inputting
a different form of that data or a file
type into that each pipeline and then I
also learned that you should be naming
everything very descriptively just to go
back on and you'd be easy to find what
you're looking for and then to always do
test runs and proofread everybody that I
worked with at the G and lab could not
stress this enough and using the echo
command because when you're executing
and bash scripting um your data you
don't want to do anything that could
make some irreversible damage to your
data and it's always just good to test
it out first and proofread and make sure
you don't have any little typos that
will make the command run and then I
learned that patience is key when
studying brains and working with newly
developed tools so the summer I did a
lot of navigating and programming in the
command line as well as cloud computing
and I was working a lot in extra cloud
and every time I would get someone to
help me they'd be like Oh what are you
working in like Rushmore or the AARC and
then I'll be home working EXA cloud it
everyone just sighs really loud because
um it could be really slow and there's a
lot of problems with it like for example
I could run the pipeline on one day and
then the next day I'd do the exact same
thing and it won't run and I don't know
why and then the next day it will run
perfectly so it's just them
understanding that studying brains and
working with advanced technology is
going to be difficult and it's going to
take time and then to take advantage of
experts in the room I was lucky enough
to have a just in the deccan lab which
is essentially a huge room with just a
bunch of computers so I sat around their
computing team and whenever I needed
assistance help or like any questions I
knew that I could just get up and like
ask my neighbor like hey I need help and
they would come over and help me out so
just like to acknowledge I'm dr.
Karstens for taking me on this summer as
well as her collaborators dr. demian
fair and the DCAM lab and then dr. Rahel
Nardo's and then demise and then
developmental cognition in an eroge
aiming lab that i worked in and the
National Library of Medicine grant I
made this internship possible thank you
[Applause]
working okay my name is Peter graven I
am a data scientist in itg with Oh
chi-su we had for the summer
Dave door is also a member of the
internship project that Ian schipper has
been working on so he we're excited to
have him he's kind of the first intern
in this data science and advanced
modeling that we've been doing and so
it's been really it's been great
experience for us and hopefully for him
as well
we had been we kind of played around
with a couple different possible topics
for the summer that were related to
projects we had that were necessary and
he really gravitated on to wanting to
create his own predictive model and test
some new some of the new techniques or
whatever that we were that he was
interested in and getting comfortable
with that so it's been a great
experience we've liked having him and
hope to do it again in the future
major at st. Olaf College and we're
going to be talking about the use of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence in healthcare specifically
in risk stratification so there's a
quick overview of what we're going to be
doing we're going to talk about why this
project in particular and why we're
looking at such a specific subset of
patients we're going to talk about the
data that we've been working with and a
lot of the features of it as well as the
cleaning and formatting which was a
whole task and a half then we're gonna
get into some modeling the results and
then where this projects gonna go in the
future so there's a little disclaimer
this project is very much in the works
all the models I'm going to be talking
about today are actually old models
we've got new ones that are running
right now on my computer down on the
waterfront and so it's still very
exciting and so without further ado just
a brief overview of Who I am that is
from Lima as the Songhai yeah anyway so
just a little explanation of why a music
majors sitting here talking about AI
I'm also an economics major I do most of
my work with healthcare economics and
predictive modeling done a lot of work
with billing and so it's nice to get a
bit of a change of pace and work a
little more patient side so that's a bit
why I'm here talking about AI and not
something a little more appropriate to
music such as the eye surgeon who
managed to kill both johann sebastian
bach and georg friedrich händel and I
promise that is my only music fact for
this presentation so that should save
you some distress so this has been a
great project with a great team myself
I'm the intern I've been working mostly
with the modeling as well as some data
formatting David Orr and Peter graven
were both my mentors in this David aura
did a lot of informatics work as well as
talking us through some of the work
that's been similar to this since he's
done it quite a bit of it and Peter's
been kind of coordinating the whole
effort and and getting us through what
kind of models we need what models we
want and where we're gonna go with this
Conrad has been doing a lot of work with
statistics he's been handling a lot of
the data cleaning and formatting because
it is a lot of work that I am truth be
told not super great at
and so he's been helping a lot with that
as well as with logistic modeling and
then faiza Khan and Ben or well both
worked on retrieving data from epic and
helping us kind of understand different
clinical aspects since Peter Conrad and
I are all either statisticians data
scientists or economists so we don't
have a whole lot of clinical knowledge
so if you asked me what is a normal
value for a creatinine lab I would just
smile and blink at you until you told me
so that's kind of who we're working with
here so this project risk stratification
has a lot of uses especially with
predictive modeling and we can take a
patient population that is that
particular particularly high risk of
having an adverse outcome this could be
something like going to the emergency
room this could be incurring
exceptionally high costs which is in
excess of $30,000 or this could be being
hospitalized so these are all things
that we would like to avoid and we've
actually come up or not come up we have
been introduced to a specific
intervention that we would like to use
which involves it's called Tablas tablet
based patient monitoring where we send
specific particularly high-risk patients
home with a tablet and so they can
continue the monitoring process that
goes on in the hospital at home during
their outpatient treatment and this is
particularly important for cancer
patients because cancer patients have a
whole host of other problems that most
patients don't have to deal with
especially if they've undergone
chemotherapy as chemotherapy affects the
body in a whole bunch of different ways
it can compromise your immune system it
can cause severe nausea and so there's a
lot of problems that could seem very
severe but might be perfectly normal for
a patient with that cancer in that
treatment or they could actually be
incredibly severe and so this tablet
monitoring gives us the ability to have
them report in to their doctor and say
this is what's going on is this normal
and so yeah that's what we've got it's
we have about 20 tablets in total that
we can send home and as we'll go over
later we're talking about a patient
population though we're talking about
83,000 people and so we can only send 20
home and so we want to be really sure
that the 20 we sent home are with the
right people and so it does have kind of
limitations of resources and so we want
to make sure the right people get these
okay so the data data comes from care
everywhere which includes OHSU and other
organ health care providers and so we're
primarily concerned with only the
patients who have had an office visit
and are undergoing treatment at OHSU and
so that's one of the ways we pared down
I think we started with somewhere around
90,000 and we cut about 7,000 patients
who did not receive their treatment at
OHSU
but those 83,000 may have gone elsewhere
for an emergency room visit or a
hospitalization and so we want to be
able to capture that even though they
are at OHSU patient and so we have I
think seven different data sets that we
pulled from these our data sets of
office visits edy visits
hospitalizations we have two million lab
results of 2,000 independent labs we
have their demographic information we
have more patient information it is a
whole bunch of stuff that we had to pare
together and so the way we did that is
every patient has a patient ID and every
encounter has an encounter ID so let's
say a patient goes to the emergency room
that visit will have its ID and it will
have their patient ID and then let's say
they get a lab done that lab result will
go into the lab data set under their
patient ID and encounter ID so we can
say this lab came from dis let's say
they get diagnosed with a certain
disease that diagnosis codes goes into
its own data set with their patient ID
and encounter ID so you can see we're
kind of pulling from a lot of different
places to create a single data set and
so the final data set had 82,000 913
patients with 212 different variables
these variables are primarily
0/1 indicators of do they have this
diagnosis or not do they have this lab
result as a high or not do they have
this cancer or no and so that makes it a
lot easier when we come to modeling so
yeah we've got 83,000 patients in the
year 2018
be predicting there edy visits in 2019
eventually but the models that I have
are all predicting on their 2018 data
sets in order to see can we accurately
predict their eg visits based on all of
this data and we have a bit of a problem
in that very few of the cancer patients
that we have actually went to the
emergency department in 2018
it's about 6% and so if you have a naive
model which is a model that only
predicts one thing you could just say no
one's going to go to the emergency
department and you'd be right 94% of the
time which is a really really good model
and so we need to be able to beat that
there's a couple different ways we can
do that and then there's a few ways that
we can get lower accuracy but be able to
catch a higher number of the patients
we're actually interested in those
high-risk patients so now we're gonna
get into a brief overview of the
modelling that we're doing the
techniques that we use I'm gonna go
really quickly over logistic regression
because I'm not going to talk about any
of the logit models since I didn't make
them it was all Conrad's work then I'm
gonna go over random forests
classification and artificial neural
networks so a logistic regression is
probably the one that most of you are at
least somewhat familiar with this
creates a linear function to predict a
probability or a log odds of a zero or a
one and so you can come out with zero
one indicator of say are you gonna go to
the emergency department and the
advantage of these is that they're
pretty computationally inexpensive the
average logit model takes for me about
five to ten seconds to run that's going
to be a market difference that we're
gonna see later but they are actually
rather simple and they're good for
simple relationships but if you have a
nonlinear relationship or if you have
something that just it's more
complicated they can tend to struggle
and they're also very prone to
overfitting where if you include
collinearity it doesn't it's not quite
robust enough to deal with that and so
we get to the random forest models which
are kind of the next step up in being
complicated and it's a quite a big step
so what these do is these will create
a number of decision trees and this
little graphic over to the right is
actually a pretty good idea of what each
decision tree looks like where you start
with a number of instances of inputs
it'll undergo a bunch of logical
functions in order to come out with a
single output and so the average tree
has the average random forest has about
500 trees and it will run all 500 of
those trees on every observation so if
we're looking at a data set of 83,000
people times 500 trees we've got about
45 million trees which is more trees
than there are in the state of Oregon so
these are big models they are hard to
understand and they get out of hand
very fast and so the average model that
I had would take about 20 to 25 minutes
to run I've had them go as long as two
and a half to three hours or if you have
a particularly slow computer a weekend
and so these are really useful for more
complicated relationships they handle
nonlinear relationships incredibly well
because it handles each instance of a
numerical value as its own thing so it
separates say a zero to ten into ten
different points that could each have a
nonlinear relationship to your output
and the final one is artificial neural
networks
fortunately for I think the human race
I'm not super great at making a thinking
machine but I can make one that can do a
binary classification pretty dang well
and so what this does is essentially
attempts to replicate the way the human
brain works you have a layer of input
neurons which will have values so for
each variable you have a different
neuron those will undergo then a layer
of several hidden layers of neurons
which include logical functions in order
to say okay is this true then you're
going to go over there is false you're
going to go over there and so it
undergoes all of that until you get to a
single output layer so I only did one
artificial neural network for this
because they are quite complicated and
quite computationally expensive my model
had about three hidden layers the
general rule of thumb is each layer will
contain 2/3 the number of inputs of
neurons
as the previous layer until you get down
to a single one and yet these are very
very very expensive the one that I made
took about 48 hours to run constantly I
kind of left it there for a weekend and
came back and it was still chugging away
so these are not the greatest if you
don't have a whole bunch of time and
we're gonna run into an issue later of
importing these into the reporting
workbench for use in epic so now that we
know kind of what the models are we have
a few struggles machine learning models
do exactly what it sounds like they
learn from the data and so if you don't
have a lot of positive instances of
something they can have trouble learning
from them so in this case we only have
6%
edie visits and so it learns ET visits
are very very rare and they're probably
not going to happen
so I'm best off just hedging my bets and
saying you're not going to go to the
emergency department that's not what we
want and so um there's kind of two ways
that we can do that we can change
function parameters or the way I chose
to do we can change what data it's
trained on so what I did for that is I
created a separate data set that has
2,000 observations 1,000 of which did
not go to the emergency room and 1,000
of which did so I tricked the model into
thinking emergency room visits happen
about half of the time and so you should
learn what causes people to go to the
emergency room and this does cause it to
suffer in terms of accuracy but as we
see it'll help us in sensitivity and so
accuracy is while a great metric is not
the one we're primarily concerned with
we're concerned with positive predictive
value and sensitivity so positive
predictive value tells us of the things
that we have classified as positive how
many were actually positive so this is
our confidence that if we say you're
high risk you are actually high risk
which is important because we only want
to give tablets to those who are high
risk and then sensitivity which is how
many of the high risk patients did we
actually catch so I'll be talking about
five models we have a full
representative model which uses all
variables at our disposal and uses a
representative set of the data we split
our data into a training and testing
to avoid overfitting as much as we can
80% of our data was in the training set
and 20% in the testing set so that was
trained on the full 80 percent training
set a full even model which uses all of
the variables and uses my special even
data set in order to condition it a
reduced representative model which uses
a reduced subset of variables and the
way we reduced those as we looked which
specifically which HCC diagnosis codes
are most highly correlated with
instances of emergency room Department
and we took the top ten of those and
included those in our model and we did
the same for lDA's which are lion
strains and Airways and for labs
and for cancers and we used a set of
demographic information so that was
trained on all the data the reduced used
the same set of reduced variables and
used the altered even subsets and then
my artificial neural network which I
call an used a further reduced set of
variables because artificial neural
networks can only handle numerical or
complex vector arguments and so if you
try to put in a categorical variable it
will just cry and give up so the results
I listed out the true positive true
negative false positive and false
negative if you're interested we can see
our accuracies are pretty good the two
full and the two representative models
have above that 94% accuracy which is
exactly what we're looking for so these
are doing better than a naive model but
we can look at their sensitivity and see
it's about 10% which is pretty bad and
their positive predictive values are not
what we would like either the even on
the other hand have a slightly lower
accuracy but still pretty decent at 82%
but we can see their sensitivity gets
much better with 61 percent accuracy and
58 percent in the other case and then
the artificial neural network has
slightly worse accuracy slightly better
sensitivity is there's kind of a nice
middle-of-the-road model
so going forward I mentioned integrating
these into the reporting workbench what
that is is in epic we can put in a model
with all of our data manipulation in
order to turn raw input from physicians
into an output of a prediction of a risk
and there's a few problems here that
we're gonna run into and that is what
the epic servers are programmed to
handle and what they're compatible with
so they're compatible with all linear
models all logistic models and simple
random forest models so notably
artificial neural networks are not yet
programmed int to be put into the
reporting workbench so unfortunately an
is kind of useless to us at this point
and the more complicated random forest
models are just not ready to be put into
the epic workbench because they're
they're too complicated they're too
computationally expensive and doing so
would just bog down the whole system and
once we do that we'll move on to patient
trials in which they'll actually be used
and we'll say okay which are the highest
risk patients and we'll send them home
with tablets and we'll see if that
actually helps them and hopefully it
will says some thank yous the national
library of medicine training grant of
course the department of medical
informatics including clinical
epidemiology as well as i'm peter graven
and his team and the care management
plus team down at 30-30 moody who have
so graciously accommodated me in their
office even though i do some pretty
different work from them they've been
great colleagues and helped quite a bit
both my presentation poster research
techniques and the like thank you
[Applause]
hey thank you a great presentation
um one specific thing I was wondering
about you said that they're only 20
tablets have you tried looking at what
happens if you give like the top 20
highest risk well give you know if you
pretend that you had done that with the
20 that were labeled as being highest
risk and you see how many of them
actually did end up coming back to the
IDI how many of them did you miss yes
thank you actually I forgot to mention
that we did look at of the top 20 that
the model classifies which ones have the
highest accuracy I didn't include it
here but the accuracies were much lower
than what it stated in the accuracy for
the complete model but still on the
higher side between 50 and 75 percent
for all of them which it's up to the
institution if that's an acceptable
level of risk of catching 25% not
actually high risk patients and so
that's adds up to people who are not me
but it does have some some promising
aspects to it it's the best and why um
it really depends on your thought
process of what you prioritize if you
prioritize prioritize acts accuracy
above all else the reduced
representative model is going to be your
best bet and 96.7 percent accuracy if
you're valuing sensitivity so catching
the most number of actual high-risk
patients for instance if we have say a
larger number of tablets in the future
and we want to make sure we help as many
of the high-risk patients I would say
that the full even model would be the
best because it catches the highest
percentage of high-risk patients it
depends what you prioritize well it
seems like you have a metric because you
only have 20 tablets right now to do
this study with so it would seem that
the right metric would be you know the
precision at 20 which yeah you know how
in which case it would be the full
representative a 75% accuracy and you
said you get so although at 20 I guess
all the predictions are positive
yeah so all the predictions are positive
and 15 actually went to the emergency
department so 75% accuracy that's
probably pretty good I don't know Peter
can give you an economic analysis if
that makes it worth doing this study but
it sounds like that would be reasonable
to me right and models even get close to
that um the reduced representative had a
little over 50 percent which is not bad
again better than sticking a cat and
saying here decide who gets a tablet but
ideally you'd want the highest accuracy